SPEAKER: In this video,
we'll discuss how to handle
a cancelled subscription and
how to help a user restore
their subscription if they want.
Before we begin, you'll want
to have real-time developer
notification set up.
To learn how to do this,
be sure to check out
our real-time developer
notifications video.
With real-time
developer notifications,
you'll receive a notification
when a subscription is
cancelled or restored.
After receiving
this notification,
call the Google
Play Developer API
from your server to record the
new subscription information.
When a subscription
is cancelled,
the user retains access to
your service until the end
of the billing period.
During this time, you
can offer the user
the option to restore
their subscription
before the expiration.
You need to enable this
functionality via the Google
Play console.
Sign into your Play console,
and select your app.
On the left menu, click Store
Presence, In-app Products.
Select the Subscriptions tab,
and expand the Subscription
Settings section.
Check the box Allow Users
to Restore Subscriptions.
Then provide a message in
your app that tells the user
that their subscription has
expired or will expire soon.
Be sure to include a deep link
to the Google Play Subscription
Center in this message so they
can restore their subscription
or fix their payment method.
For more information on
setting up deep links,
visit the link onscreen.
The message should be respectful
of the user's decision
to cancel, so it should
be easy to ignore
and easy for the user
to permanently dismiss
this notice.
To learn more, visit
the link onscreen,
or check out our other videos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]